[Music]
it was past midnight but I was ready the
next day I meet with the CEO and other
senior leaders of my global consulting
firm I talk about the work we were doing
as employee resource groups and our
progress in diversity and inclusion for
the past two years I had been leading
our LGBTQ and Ally employee resource
group and we were doing great things
we had expanded to over 25 offices
globally we were increasing awareness
and support across geographies these
were just a few of the wins that I was
really excited to talk about the next
day earlier I had rehearsed with the
head of our diversity and inclusion team
she was thrilled by the presentation
there was just one last thing that I had
to do she asked me if I was going to
wear my nail polish to the meeting
now I didn't think much of it in the
moment I would often take off my nail
polish to meet with clients but that
night it felt different I couldn't help
but feel as I went finger by finger that
I was removing a part of myself now I
get that nail polish seems like
something trivial but to me it is so
tied to my identity it's like my cross
or my hijab and that I wear it as a
symbol to the world about my queerness
and I wear it as a symbol to myself
about Who I am and my journey I wear it
like armor to feel confident and to
overcome the insecurities that I have
felt for so many years so that night I
had an aha moment I thought maybe I've
slipped through a crack in our DNI
tonight I'm gonna talk about the work
being done in diversity and inclusion
I'm gonna talk about what's going well
and how it can be improved in doing so
I'm going to emphasize the importance of
thinking more about individuality in our
worked in DNI as practitioners business
leaders and people so for those of you
who aren't quite sure what DNI is
diversity and inclusion
it's a firm's formal set of activities
to create a workplace where people of
all backgrounds feel welcomed and valued
it includes things like non-biased
trainings mentorship programs and
recruitment initiatives when it's done
well it can have business impacts in
fact in a recent survey 85% of CEOs so
that DNI programs were improving their
bottom lines they talked about things
like greater innovation access to new
markets and retaining talent better so
it's clear that Dee and I can improve
business performance but DNI is not just
about bottom lines Wendy and I has done
well it can have big impacts on
individuals that means all of us even
with my story about the nail polish I'd
still argue that DNI is essential as a
queer person I have a long complicated
relationship with my identity so when
I'm in a workplace where I feel included
I don't have to stress about fitting in
or if I'm being judged I can put all of
my brainpower into my work I deliver
better results and I feel motivated to
do so now I assume others in the
audience tonight have had similar
experiences about DNI and feeling
included and that underscores the value
of DNI for all of us so now that we've
talked a little bit about why DNI is
important I want us to think about the
ways that our current approaches may
actually be holding us back
so traditionally DNI is organized around
categorical groups think women veterans
people of color this is great and it
does bring a lot of value to firms
but it's not perfect
I'll focus on two limitations in
particular the first is how we think
about the diversity within categories
and the second is how we handle
intersectionality which is the interplay
across our different identities so for
this first idea of the diversity within
categories let's go back to my original
story it's true that we were having a
lot of success for the LGBTQ community
but as I realized firsthand
it wasn't success for everyone in that
community
more specifically we weren't doing
enough for trans and queer people like
myself see there was a problem with
working with a group we weren't seeing
who wasn't at the table and we were
getting a false positive on our success
so as companies work on D&I they need to
look critically at the converse at the
composition of their diverse communities
ask in my company does LGBTQ actually
include l.g be T and Q in any company is
every woman white or is every black
employee a man we need to take these
into consideration to advance our DNI so
having talked about this first
limitation around the diversity within
categories let's think about the second
limitation around intersectionality
again this is the interplay across our
different identities and for this I'm
going to talk about the experience of my
friend Erika a black woman again
traditional DNI would organize programs
around categorical groups and there
would be programs for black employees
and others for women and Erika would opt
in to both but in her words she wouldn't
really be there as her full self she'd
be black Eric out of lunch and later
that day
woman Erika at a dinner it sounds
strange right now we're all different
but we're all similar and that we are
all complex
we're all a combination of identities
some visible most invisible and so we
can all have this experience where it's
hard to be present as our full selves
when we're only being viewed as
categories so when working in D&I we
need to make sure we're designing it for
whole people so having talked about
these two limitations the first the
diversity within categories and the
second intersectionality let's think of
what we can do to get beyond them I
would suggest that working more around
this idea of individuality is a start
and what might that look like well could
take the shape of storytelling think of
the impact of erica's and my stories
tonight think of the impact they and
others could have in sparking
discussions and shaping workplace
culture it could take the shape of
events that celebrate intersectionality
and all of our identities visible and
invisible taken together these kinds of
programs help us overcome the current
limitations of our work we can see and
support new pools of talent we can let
people show up and participate as their
whole selves and not just their parts
each of these incremental gains improves
inclusivity which should attract new
forms of diversity which should lead to
even better outcomes when I reflect on
my experience I probably wouldn't have
joined my firm if it didn't have DNI I
probably would have opted out of
consulting and business altogether for
me it would have been easier not to
exist in those worlds than to feel
unwelcome or excluded but what if I did
what value would have been lost to my
company my clients and myself
DNI gave me a reason to opt in and
it's not perfect it's certainly part of
the reason why I'm here now so I'm
preparing for this moment I had to ask
myself should I take off my nail polish
I can still be insecure in a lot of
settings especially ones like this but
I'm proud to stand up here tonight armor
on and ready to go to battle for a
greater focus on individuality in our
work in DNI because diversity and
inclusion is business
smart but designing it for individuals
that's what makes it human thank you
[Music]